the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing we have in the UK
different genres of uh music okay
different genres which people outside
the UK might not
know um before in my time it used to be
called Grime yeah and then they they
changed it I don't know when this
happened when maybe someone can tell me
when happened but they changed it
something called drill
okay when they start drilling people and
then um and that that's that was
PA don't get involved yeah don't get
involved but one of the is he a drill
artist or is he a garage artist I don't
know he's he's one of the two yeah yeah
his name is uh
AJ Tracy and he's appeared on uh uh
trunks's podcast chunks right chunks and
Philly and he had the following to say
about Islam let's let's watch it
together so I want to move on and talk
about religion cuz you've shown some
interest in religion in particular Islam
um are you planning on converting that's
a techy question bro that's te question
I
li
question I'm I writing also assuming
before you answer that your Ms is Muslim
yeah yeah yeah my Ms my uncle my my best
friends my cousins everyone yeah bro the
Muslim oh no wait in Islam in Islam the
woman can she marry someone that's non
Muslim or can she no she can't marry
somebody that's non Muslim but the the
man as long as abrahamic if was an
abrahamic Faith bro I grew up in big
Moroccan Community you get me when I go
to E Ro and kolov you me with the man's
Muslim so I've been around in my whole
life when my friends and Family's um
people's pass away we go to the mosque
and we pray you get and I know what
everyone's going to say to this but bro
I'm just doing my research and learning
about it and when I'm ready inshallah
I'm revert get if not then if not but if
it is it is hopefully I do blah blah
blah you get but I do feel slightly
uncomfortable I know what you're going
to say to this already I know the answer
cuz bman told me this but I feel
uncomfortable doing certain things that
I know are blatantly Haram and reverting
and then obviously for a revert as well
and I'm online you get people's going to
be like so why would you go and do that
for you to just go and you get and I no
this this the truth I'd rather die a
Muslim even if I was sinning than die
without reverting that's the truth
interesting but he's he's made the
argument for himself I think when he
said that well I'd rather die as a
Muslim you know and this is this is
actually a very it means that you've
actually already arrived at the
conclusion which is that you believe
that there's only one God worthy of
worship you don't believe that there's a
man as God you don't believe Jesus as
God you don't believe that in the
Trinity you don't believe for example in
the Incarnation you don't believe in the
in these tenants of Christianity you
don't you're not an atheist so if this
is the case what do you really have to
lose this is the question is by being a
Muslim you don't have anything to lose
you've got everything to lose by not
being a Muslim you know and you know
this is in in mathematics there's a guy
called Pascal and some say this is
Pascal's wager they called it Pascal's
wah which is the idea that well let's
say for example Islam is true for the
sake of argument okay and some say no
this is not a good argument but this is
actually in the Quran and I can explain
this in a second yeah but let's say for
the sake of argument Islam is true and
you die upon what you're upon so if you
die upon what you're upon okay then then
what then you going to hell knowing
knowing what you know knowing that if
you reject Islam if you reject the one
God if you reject the
prophet go to the Hellfire and not only
that in this life you might live A
disgraced life you might live A
humiliating life to be honest with you
cuz I don't want to just offer you
incentive there is a considerable
disincentive however if you do become a
Muslim then the truth of the matter is
all of your sins are removed and you are
newly born you're new to the Rel
religion you're clean you're better than
all the Muslims uh and so on and so
forth and you might be thinking well I'm
living a certain life and I'm doing
certain things and I'm I'm producing
certain songs and I think that's the
biggest issue and that's why he said
that he
knows uh and I think that's what the
biggest issue is because he said even
though he knows the answer but yet he
said it again it shows the magnitude of
how that thing is weighing him down
because the the drill or the grime
industry is no alien to reverts and
Muslims yeah there's many Muslim artists
in fact one of the most popular latest
ones was D ofi he accepted Islam so he's
probably and they are probably aware of
people that accept Islam I mean even
others not even drill and grime artists
that have accepted Islam that are then
rightly so being held to a standard for
some people it might be an unrealistic
standard for some people it is a a
standard but um regardless when you're
on social media you're going to be um
you're going to be judged and uh and and
and held to some sort of metric so now
the thing is here that either you care
what people think and you fail in this
world and in the Hereafter or you accept
Islam and you you slowly slowly like
like like I think somebody said it's
it's not a race yeah you go at it's not
a race you go at your you go at your own
pace yeah so at least there is Pro
progress there is a pace so yes you
might have to hear things from people in
this world however at least you'll be
successful ultimately in this world and
in the Hereafter as well because for us
this world is minuscule it's nothing
it's you know very tiny in comparison to
the Hereafter yeah which even the day of
judgment they say will be manyfold
bigger than the life of this world so
once a person understands that that is
the main goal yes people might annoy you
and bug you but just like you don't care
about hate comments like you're you're a
rapper and although they're saying oh we
get comments and you can't do anything
right I would make the same uh argument
for drill and rap as well no matter how
wonderful your rap is there'll be
somebody that's un you know um unhappy
with a line you've said or your style or
doesn't like you because music is
subjective even lyrics as well people
might have an issue with you or beef
with you so just like you continue doing
what you're doing because you see that
this is good for me this gives me joy
this gives me happiness similarly
happiness success ultimate joy and
ultimate success comes from Islam and by
in this small bullet to get such a big
reward I think it's a it's a no
no-brainer to be honest yeah no not sure
like myself before I came to Islam same
same thing I had like a good months or
years where I was like oh I'm sinning
and let me better myself but we know in
in in Islam is that you have to pray you
have to read the Quran these are the
things that will keep you away from sins
we think no I need to stop sinning so
then I can become a Muslim no you have
to become a Muslim being a Muslim will
help you stop sinning so that's one
thing and like Zan said as well is that
when entrepreneurs go through hardship
difficulties they they tell us their
success stories yeah I used to eat bread
and beans for for three months I was
sleeping on the sofa and people giving
me hate no one believed in me you know
that guy who say you know the people
that didn't believe in me yeah so people
tell success stories by what people were
people didn't believe in me I was doing
this and I had to work and do so a
success story is based on what all the
struggles you go through it's the
struggles that make a success story have
you ever come and said it's like Donald
Trump my dad lent me a million dollars
that's not a success story bro he was
given it so if that's the case for a a a
worldly thing what about you
succeeding with all of the hate that you
you're getting from people whatever it
is that's a part of the journey just
like Donald Trump's getting hate from
you yeah exactly yeah the D give a
million dollars so I would say
personally um we can help look if you
become a Muslim uh if chunks is
connected to look Salah plus.com we can
send you a guided prayer map it can help
you learn how to pray Salah if you are
interested it's for free you can order
it will be shipped out to you you don't
need to tell us your details you can go
on there and do it yourself or chunks
can arrange it somehow I don't know it's
up to him but yeah I would say don't let
that stop you it seems like you are uh
sincere sincerity is there uh your Mrs
you said is a Muslim obviously um I'm
sure you know I don't to tell you so
obviously it's not permissible but you
know if you get married you can do your
Nik instantly you guys are both
permissible for each other the and get
married and yeah that's it I think
that'll be wonderful so hijab if AJ
Tracy has some questions and he wants to
reach out you can Instagram and we can I
mean I live in your area actually to be
honest with you can even meet person so
I mean um anytime doors are always open
really yeah and we can even even do you
ni Islamic yeah we can do that yeah I
can get done really quickly no
I in I say anything else salamu
alayum hey you are you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a dawa Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more for